staying overseas Britain is holding an
election this morning that could finally
decide the long-running brexit battle
voters are choosing all 650 members of
the House of Commons it is the country's
third general election in less than five
years but some analysts are calling it
the most important vote there in decades
Mark Phillips is in London for us this
morning mark good morning so what's
really at stake here good morning well
what's at stake here is more than who
just gets to run the country it's about
what kind of country this will be
there's even more at stake here than
whether Britain stays in or leaves the
European Union for Boris Johnson the
sitting Prime Minister this election is
about getting the parliamentary majority
he needs to bulldoze his version of
brexit through and he's provided some
visual aids to make his point he says
he'd take the United Kingdom out of the
European Union by the end of next month
his main opposition comes from the
Labour Party's Jeremy Corbyn who says
he'd negotiate yet another divorce deal
with the EU and then hold another
referendum on whether the UK should
leave he'd also nationalized many of
Britain's large public industries the
waters are even further muddied here by
the smaller parties that could split the
vote and the opinion polls show the tube
gap between the two major parties is in
fact now Erick Gayle it's unclear
whether this election will in fact sort
anything else all right mark to be
continued for sure thank you very much
reporting from London